non non j'ai pas de problème particulier
avec les mecs en chemise j'ai
l'impression que les mecs qui portent
des chemises
ils font toujours un métier qu'on
comprend pas grosso merdo jeu dans le
marketing international intergalactique
je gère des unités de management à
l'étranger notamment à new york et sur
mars
voilà après après voilà c'est un métier
où tu sais pas ce que c'est c'est trop
compliqué pour nous qui portons de
simple t-shirt finalement pas je veux
dire ils font rarement un truc très
différents bénévolement je travaille
dans un cirque et je jongle la mi temps
tout en chantant les rita mitsouko
ce qui est quand même bien avec la
chemise c'est les boutons avec les
boutons et les mecs en chemise ils
peuvent révéler leur personnalité ou
leur état d'esprit du moment
première solution entièrement bétonné
soit je sors directement d'un clip de
sortie one où j'ai un problème sérieux
avec les femmes et modou diop du pool de
boutons je fais des études de marketing
international of the world je parle
anglais et tu peux pas test de boutons
col relevé que je sais pas pourquoi mais
je me prends pour julio iglesias
trois boutons il fait carrément très
chaud tu peux rien cette semaine j'ai
super chaud
où j'essaye discrètement de me donner un
petit côté sexy dans le but de séduire
la femme
excuse moi est ce que tu veux danser la
salsa s'il te plaît oui parce que les
mecs en chemise ya que que qui danse la
salsa
nous on tee shirt on n'est pas bien
aucun bouton je commence vraiment à être
torche et où j'ai un sérieux problème
avec les femmes
évolution déboule enfin la version dance
course je travaille chez quick et j'ai
pas eu le temps de changer jours sur
place ont rapporté à emporter ça marche
oui c'est une caisse de l'invisible
après évidemment tout ça c'est des
clichés un mec en chemise ils sont pas
tous comme ça
il a même certains qui cache plutôt bien
leur jeu non moi je me suis mais bien
deux soirées du parfum je sus petit
flash de tout mais je sais ce que les
mecs en chemise dont tous derrière la
tête
c'est que les chemises ça plaît aux
femmes les filles elle a bien les mecs
en chemise pour pouvoir porter la
chemise
le lendemain matin au petit déj se joue
j'étais préparé des biscottes
c'est presque lire nous les mais
comporte pas vos vêtements le matin je
te couvrirai des miss lot après pas
forcément contre le port d'une petite
chemise
c'est pas quelque chose qui me débecte
je veux dire vous êtes de plus en plus
nombreuses sur la page facebook norman
fait des vidéos et ça c'est un fait
grave plaisir à maillezais
[Musique]
ça tombe bien
voilà sinon je plante des clous le
week-end de manière on va dire semi pro
[Musique]